it has just hosted the pope and
continues to welcome many others there's
been a sudden boom in Portugal's
popularity as a place to settle down in
and it comes with a Visa tax breaks and
a pathway to gaining nationality in a
European Union country
Sam hey from New Zealand works as an
events planner during the pandemic he
couldn't get back home so he settled in
Lisbon and liked it so much he obtained
the digital Nomad Visa you've got all
these sort of
Boutique Bohemian kind of hipstery
places showing up it's just
um
made for a city with this incredible
creative people amazing street art
around the place but there is one
drawback it's quite expensive to live
here
like housing costs quite a lot for some
time Portugal has a cheap destination
has been popular with retirees from
northern European countries looking to
settle in a warmer climate
but now that a younger digital Savvy
crowd is flocking to its Shores it's
putting pressure on the system
especially the housing sector
added to this the decision to host the
Catholic Church's World Youth Day an
event attended by 1.5 million people but
at a time when rents are outstripping
the average wage of half of the working
population many were angered by how much
money the state put towards the visit
itself the total injection of public
funds to host World Youth Day cost 41
million dollars the cost of the stage
alone was 3 million dollars and it was
used for just two days nevertheless the
city council says it was a worthwhile
investment and in the future it will be
used to host major entertainment and
sporting events it's a way they say of
promoting Lisbon as a key International
destination
there is little buzz around areas
outside of Lisbon's tourism Zone Paolo
is a clinical psychologist his main work
in the public sector does not pay enough
to cover the rent
he sold his car and has to work three
other jobs at night to be able to afford
to pay the bills
it's not enough It's never enough I have
two children to provide for I get 1 100
euros and nothing is left over that's
why I had to search for other work what
I realized is that many people like me
were professionals were part of the
upper middle class are too ashamed to
ask for help
the dream of a desirable lifestyle in
Portugal may only be available to those
who can afford it
not for those struggling to keep up with
the challenges Sonia Gallego Al Jazeera
Lisbon